It looks like it's really
worn out.
Thank you for standing up Thank you Open this after you get
home It
's special because you come every day It's going to be a
little more
good Then
hello
ah ah ah
I walked like this  Yo,
you can't open it if you don't look at it Everyone can't go out with this snow, and it seems like the convenience store
is closed, but there are people who have to shop every day, so if I open the shop now, it'll only
be profitable here.  Okay
[music]
Okay then shoveling snow Yes
, that kind of horror
thing.  Well, with those eyes, I'm not good at math It's
interesting to be so enthusiastic about business,
isn't
it?  Earn money by hitting
[music] I have
a cool bag without a labor union
Yuki When I thought I was going to draw, I only had thin rubber gloves
a Not like this, I wonder if it's a thick one that doesn't get soaked in snow
If I put those rubber gloves on from the top
Thank you very much
.